this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on the link in the description
you know what this means they're gonna
keep coming after her
personally legally in whatever way they
can take it to the judge
there will be sanctions
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer
today we are covering an oldie but a
goodie damages episode 1 starring glenn
close
and rose byrne i've never seen an
episode of damages but i've heard a lot
about it so i'm really looking forward
to this
as always be sure to comment in the form
of an objection which i will either
sustain or overrule and let me know
what movie or tv show i should do next
and of course stick around until the end
of the video where i give this episode
of damages a grade
for legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in
to damages episode 1.
[Music]
you should really shower up after you've
murdered someone
the blood is a dead giveaway ellen
i think you'll find our offer more than
fair for someone just out of law school
we'd like to bring you in as the junior
associate
five years guaranteed okay salary of
holy [ __ ] so it is very common to get
job offers right out of law school that
is one of the primary functions of law
school
is to connect aspiring lawyers with big
firms who will make offers like these
a couple things to note here number one
nobody gets a five-year guarantee out of
law school
there's just no way to know who's going
to be a good lawyer and who's not so
there's
really never such a thing as a
guaranteed employment contract
with a big law firm but that kind of
reaction to
the salary offer is somewhat realistic
because new york really sets
the bar when it comes to associate
salary right now
in new york at a big firm you can make
anywhere between 160 and 190
000 per year straight out of law school
if you go to one of the biggest firms i
don't know if this is
one of those big firms it looks very
ornate but
there are some monster salaries that are
being offered to students
right out of law school ms hughes
the verdict's coming in it's your last
chance to get off cheap
150. 50 patty tops
reggie dwayne thomas who the hell's that
a second grader and a mets fan you know
him as patient 61.
as his immune system was being decimated
reggie asked me for two things
75 did his team make the playoffs and
that someone punished the company that
made him sick
all right 150 that's it we're done
ah the good old courthouse steps
negotiation while this is clearly a
dramatization there are some kernels of
truth here because
contrary to popular belief very few
cases actually go to trial and those
that do go to trial
very few of them actually end up going
to verdict
because parties are risk averse and
while tens of millions of dollars might
seem like a huge amount and it is
obviously
to a large corporation the downside
could be even worse for example a good
friend
of mine just litigated a case against
monsanto
and won 300 million dollars
so if you're up against a 300 million or
a billion dollar verdict that could
bankrupt the company it's better to just
take your lumps get the certainty of not
having
hundreds of millions of dollars against
you by the jury
and just move on which i think is what's
happening here
i am here because of arthur frobisher
5 000 of his employees lost their life
savings as a result of his actions
alleged actions he was found not guilty
at a criminal trial
as is often the case there are different
burdens of proof depending on what court
you're in if you have a criminal
prosecution
then you have the highest burden in all
of law which is
you must prove your case as the state
beyond a reasonable doubt
the members of the jury cannot have a
single reasonable doubt in order to
convict
however what often happens is that even
if you
are acquitted in a criminal court you
can be brought to trial
in a civil court where the burden of
proof is much
lower you can get damages oh boy i
usually only get this excited when they
say the title of a movie in the movie
even if a defendant is acquitted in
criminal court then you can still
sue that person for civil damages i.e
money damages
in civil court where the burden of proof
is much much lower you just have to show
a preponderance of the evidence in other
words
if you had both sides on a scale which
side is just slightly more persuasive
than the other
so i think what's going to happen here
is that there will be a civil lawsuit
against mr frobisher
for civil damages money damages where he
might have to disgorge
some of the profits that he made or pay
civil damages
to his employees if he did something
wrong so i guess we'll see
i need you to understand this we are
engaging
in a battle with a man who will stop at
nothing to preserve his fortune high
stakes litigation is a long
and painful process that is true will
destroy us in the press he will attack
us personally
he will try to turn our lives upside
down so that we'll want to settle
meanwhile his attorneys will spin him as
the good guy
the aggrieved innocent victim
so we have to be patient and we
have to stay strong but most of all
we have to all stick together
if we do that we'll win
there is some truth to that litigation
can take literally years
i've been on cases that took five years
to get to trial and took
another few years to deal with the
appeals litigation takes a long time it
takes a huge amount of resources
and it's one of the reasons that people
settle all the time is because it's so
resource intensive
that it can take years before you get
compensation when you're clearly an
aggrieved party it's a
it's a real problem ellen uncle pete
uncle pete's been with patty longer than
any of us he's really the one who runs
everything around here
good to meet you nice to meet you it's
uh it's
me you've been working on folks who
plays 24 7.
some of our associates haven't uh
haven't been able to go home yet
that's true big firms actually do offer
dry cleaning services to keep their
associates
in the office longer
well if it isn't the maid of honor what
this is totally insane to suggest that a
partner in a major firm is going to come
down to someone's wedding to interview
them because they
rejected them for a job interview
they're going to get
hundreds of rejections a year that's
just the way that these things work
there's no such thing as this firm that
everybody has to work for right out of
law school or while you're in law school
this is this trope that exists in tv
that
just doesn't exist in reality there are
hundreds of
great firms out there there are even
lots of firms that
parallel the sort of gloria allred thing
that's going on over here
there's no reason why anyone in
particular would need to work for one
particular attorney it just it doesn't
work that way
miss hughes
[Music]
is there any way i could still interview
i think it'd be a waste of time ellen
you're hired from 1 pm to 3 he lunches
with a few of his fortune 500 pals
lobster biss kobe bean but his broker is
nowhere to be found
from 3 p.m to 6 p.m probably was at the
spa getting a full body treatment
for three hours what was he getting
waxed
6 p.m probably sure flies home in his
private jet arrives at teterboro airport
at 9 00 pm
he's home safe and sound by 10. so
somehow frobisher and his broker
communicated down to florida
but no one saw them together so this
seems like the kind of issue that would
be determined
in discovery you would get access to all
of his emails his phone records
so if there is any communication going
on they would probably have that
information they wouldn't need to do any
kind of
private investigation work to track it
down which is dramatic
for tv but is not the kind of thing that
actually happens very much in
actual litigation i guess we'll see good
news
i was able to push this through
my liquor license oh excellent thank you
oh god don't even get me started about
liquor licenses in new york
it's crazy but larry
patty hughes she's not the answer i mean
she's an egomaniac
and she's going to lose
you know why no sir because i didn't do
it
yeah i'm i'm a very rich man i make no
apologies for that
but i'm also an innocent man and i want
to come to some reasonable
solution to this if mr frosher was an
attorney here this
whole meeting would be completely
inappropriate if you know that someone
is represented by
counsel as another attorney you cannot
reach out to the party directly you have
to go through counsel
but there is no rule that prohibits two
clients themselves from
talking things out even when there's
litigation pending that being said it's
a really really bad
idea because the lawyers are there to
act as intermediaries and they are there
to hash things out dispassionately
whereas when you get the clients
together talking things out
it never goes right and i'm guessing
that things are not going to go right in
this episode either
i think that you and i together
could end this and we'll
we'll be discreet we'll take care of you
this is all settled but
[Music]
not good is a number that you think is
fair
yeah that's one of the reasons you don't
have clients meet individually amongst
each other
especially here where this guy seems to
be representing a class or a whole group
of people who've been wronged by this
company
you can't conspire with a defendant and
then screw over
all the other members of the class for
your own personal gain
this is exactly why you want lawyers in
the room to prevent any kind of
shenanigans because
lawyers know that they can get disbarred
for this kind of nonsense
frobisher's net worth is upwards of two
and a half billion dollars
now a hundred million sounds like a lot
of money and it is
but it's less than five percent of what
this man is worth
i think we have a strong case it doesn't
matter how much the defendant is worth
it matters how much you're going to get
as a result of the litigation
i don't know the specifics of this case
but glenn close here may be doing a big
disservice to
all of those class members because when
you're thinking about a potential
recovery there are a couple things you
need to take into account not just the
top line number
number one no recovery is certain let's
say that there
is a 10 chance that you're going to win
everything that you think you do well
if you think you're entitled to a
billion dollars then a 10
chance means that that's worth about 100
million dollars
on top of that there's the time value of
money say you get a full recovery but it
takes you five to ten years to get that
well
a lot of people would rather have a
smaller amount right now that's the net
present value of the recovery and then
on top of that there are all the
attorneys fees and court costs
that it's going to take to litigate this
thing to the end
so those are some of the reasons why you
might take a smaller amount
up front with the certainty of getting
it than to have to deal with
years of litigation and potentially
never being able to recover
if the defendant is judgment proof and
goes bankrupt so you got to take those
things into consideration
i'd like to take it to a jury and let
them decide what mr arthur
frobisher owes you yeah i'll bet you
would
but that might not be in their interest
look at her normally she turns this [ __ ]
down she hates awards
and why is she here
another tool most cases you get your
clients 100 million
you're a hero what a frog wisher gets
off that easy
the whole legal world will know she
tanked it that is not true
at all tom here is a vegan only for
health reasons health reasons
that's weird i read an interview once
with a nobel prize winner a
physicist genius married six times he
said don't have kids
ruins your ambition keeps you from what
you want in life
he said to have wives instead you can
leave wise
you can't leave your own kids what is
she signing
why does she need to sign a hundred
different pieces of paper
[Laughter]
you know what i like about you no
there's always something going on
what's redeemable about her character
she's done nothing
and you don't fall
okay i guess
she seems like a blank slate that
everyone just projects what they want
onto her
patty hughes has a new associate
so what i thought they voted to accept
the settlement
well i haven't gotten a call yet i'm
worried
the new associate's been talking to
katie connor who
oh chef
ray whatever it takes fix this
uh oh witness tampering don't witness
damper
saffron david if i don't tell patty
about katie
the clients lose the case i'm not sure
that you can be totally objective
about this what is that supposed to mean
that you'll score points with patty
[Music]
i would never do anything to hurt katie
then just keep her out of this
what yeah
sorry saffron but how would that even
get her to testify or not testify what
are they trying to accomplish here
quiet oh my god all right
so if you were a lawyer and you paid
someone to
kill a potential witness's dog that is
certainly a disbarrable offense
i really don't even think that that
would help keep that witness quiet she
doesn't
know anything here what are these people
doing
you know what this means they're gonna
keep coming after her
personally legally in whatever way they
can
take it to the judge there will be
sanctions
ellen
i don't take this for granted
i know how hard it is for you
well if katie can help the case then
we're doing the right thing
are you do everything in my power to
protect her
good lawyers don't really have that much
power to protect people they're not
the police or the fbi that's kind of a
hollow promise
if this had happened in one of my cases
i immediately would have taken this
information to the judge
i would have asked for the police of the
fbi to start investigating it this is a
serious
crime when you have witness tampered and
you've killed someone's dog i mean
never mess with someone's dog this is a
serious problem that should result in
sanctions against the defendant if not
more criminal charges against
the defendant or his attorneys i mean
this is not a small thing this
is clearly something that deserves its
own investigation and
you shouldn't just sweep it under the
rug and just continue the litigation as
if nothing has happened
maybe one of these days i'll stop being
impressed
ellen figures out why you hired her and
you still get her to deliver the witness
you don't need to deliver a witness
are you interviewing for a new associate
no i like ellen i think she's gonna have
a brilliant future oh come on
okay so they killed the dog to force
ellen's friend to testify but if they
knew anything about litigation
all they would have to do is to issue a
subpoena against a friend and then
depose the friend
regardless of whether she wanted to or
not it's so stupid to
try and reverse blackmail or reverse
witness tamper
it doesn't even sound like she was
really on the fence in the first place
there are mechanisms to do this in
litigation you deal with witnesses who
don't want to testify
all the time ugh
these people are terrible lawyers
terrible lawyers
yeah souvenir for the dog you murdered
for no reason
[Music]
okay so now it's time to give the first
episode of damages a grade for legal
realism
oh boy you know it started out strong
but it really took a nosedive there at
the end it started out with some really
good negotiations some
interesting interplay between defendants
and a class of representatives uh
realistic sort of negotiations and back
and forth but then it took a nosedive
and turned into a soap opera with
witness tampering for no reason ignoring
the rules of civil procedure they could
have gotten everything that they wanted
just through
normal channels in litigation but they
don't really seem to be great lawyers
so all in all i'm giving the first
episode of damages
a c plus patty hughes and ellen parsons
failed at being good lawyers
learning to think like a lawyer really
means learning a broad range of topics
and always learning new skills
for example i always wanted to know how
to buy good wine that i will actually
like so i started taking this course on
wine tasting by gary vaynerchuk on
skillshare
i hate having to guess my way through a
wine list when really all i want is a
good wine to go with dinner
so i'm finally learning the fundamentals
of tasting selecting and shopping for
wine
skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 20
000 classes on everything like cuisine
design
technology you name it if you've ever
wanted to learn something odds are they
have a class
the free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things
and you'll get two free months of
skillshare when you click on the link
below
it's a special offer just for legal
eagles so click the link
get two free months and start learning
today so until next time
i'll see you in court